وسطه هدير المعارك على جبهات اوكرانيا
الساخنه يعود الحديث من طرفي الحرب عن
مفاوضات السلام وان وفق محددات متباينه
فلكل من موسكو وكييف منظوره المختلف بشان
كيفيه الوصول الى حل دبلوماسي يؤكد رئيس
الروسي ان بلاده جاهزه للتفاوض على حلول
مقبوله مع جميع الاطراف لحل الصراع في
اوكرانيا ويتهم
وداعيها برفض الجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات
بوتين اعتبر ان جذور الصراع تعود الافعال
السلطات الاوكرانيه القاسيه ضد المدنيين
في اقليم دوم بس مضطر بلاده الى الدفاع
عنهم فهي بذلك تحمي مصالحها الوطنيه
ومواطنيها في المقابل تتهم رئاسه
الاوكرانيه موسكو بعدم الرغبه في التفاوض
وانها تحاول فقط التنصله من مسؤوليتها عن
قتل المدنيين والرئيس الامريكي يؤكد العزم
على مواصله الدفاع من اراضي اوكرانيا
ويؤكد ان الاوكرانيين سيصنعون ما سماها
معجزه العيد هذا العام بالرغم من الهجمات
والتهديدات والابتزاز النووي والارهاب
والهجمات الصاروخيه
[موسيقى]
قبل الربيع والعشرين من فبراير الماضي اي
يوم عبرت الدبابات الروسيه الحدود
الاوكرانيه كانت موسكو تتحدث عن ضمانات
امنيه يجب تحقيقها لكي لا تستخدم القوه ضد
اوكرانيا وعلى راسها عدم انضمامك للنتو
وعن ضروره تنفيذ اتفاق منسك اثنين الذي
كان يقضي بان يسحب الجيش الاوكراني اسلحته
الثقيله بعيدا عن خطوط التماس مع القوات
الانفصاليه في دنيه ولكزس وان تمنح
المقاطتان الحكم الذاتي لكن الحاله تغير
كثيرا بعد مرور 10 اشهر على اندلاع الحرب
فوفق التقدير الروسي لم تعد لوجانس
ودنياسك وحدهما جزء من اراضي روسيا بل
اضيف اليهما كل من ذا براجيا واخرسون ولا
يعرفون ان كان مفهوم الحل المقبول بالنسبه
لموسكو يمكن ان يشمله تخليها عن تلك
الخطوات في المقابل تتمسك اوكرانيا بان
الحله يبدا من سحاب روسيا من لكل اراضيها
قبل الحديث عن اي ضمانات وهي لا تتحدث فقط
عن الاقاليم الاربعه بل حتى عن شبه جزيره
القرم التي حسمت موسكو ضمها اليها قبل
اكثر من ثمان سنوات
تطورات وتصريحات قد تشيء بان الطريقه نحو
السلام لا يزال بعيدا فحتى تركيا التي
يمكن ان توصف بانها البلد الوحيد الذي
يحظى بثقه الطرفين والسبق له النجاح
بتحقيق اختراقات كما حدث باتفاق تصدير
الحبوب صرح وزير دفاعا خالص يا اكار بان
الحرب في اوكرانيا لا يبدو انها ستنتهي
بسهوله وانها ستستمر العام القادم رغم
دعوته الى تحقيق وقف لاطلاق النار لاسباب
الانسانيه على الاقل